this right here is selena gomez's
striking watercolor tattoo on her upper
back the singer's new ink was revealed
by tattoo artist bang bang who showed
off cell's latest body art on instagram
i love it fans are finally getting to
see the design close up since bang bang
first shared this black and white sneak
peek on december 15th and now that
they've seen it they're not wasting any
time showing selena a lot of love in the
comments
in fact the selenators are actually
speculating about the symbolism behind
the dripping rose with some guessing
it's a nod to her namesake the queen of
tejano music selena quintanilla and her
iconic song como laflore
[Music]
or maybe this could be selena hinting at
a new album at least that's what fans
are hoping for i'm excited speaking of
music selena recently earned her first
grammy nomination for her spanish
language album revelacion
[Music]
e.t chatted with the songstress earlier
this month and she reacted to the big
honor i cried like a little baby i was
very excited
and i worked really hard on that project
so it was
a lovely surprise i'm very excited
but that's not the only trophy selena is
up for in 2022 she's also nominated for
a critics choice award for her
performance on hulu's only murders in
the building i think we should just hit
him with the charm good
excellent so i'll take the lead on this
excuse me well i can turn on the charm
is it on now
it's just warming up e.t caught up with
selena back in august when she was
promoting the show with her co-stars
steve martin and martin short helena
what was it like for you to get the call
to work with these legends and what are
you walking away from uh from this
experience with i'll answer that for her
oh stop no i had i had a great time as
you can tell i could barely keep a
straight face just hanging out with them
it was so wonderful and i learned so
much being around them they're legends
in their own right but they've you know
they're good people humble funny kind
and professional and it was just the
best martin how close did uh this trio
get on set how much fun did you guys
have together and what's your favorite
behind-the-scenes memory you'll keep
steve and i knew each other for years of
working together selena i never met
until i was the first day of shooting
and she was in the makeup chair and
right away i could tell
within five minutes she was fabulous
funny loose and wanted
the set to be the way
we all ideally wanted and how's this for
a full circle moment selena's close pal
cara delevingne who's joining the cast
for season two actually got the same
watercolor rose tattoo you know what
they say the friends that get inked
together stay together